[Music]
this is a pig like you've never seen
before
mostly because you don't have x-ray
vision but a brilliant new technology is
exposing bones in unprecedented detail
in living moving animals this is ex ROM
it's the harmonious union of CT scans
and x-rays video so the x-ray movies are
2d the bone shape is 3d but that's not
moving and so by combining the motion
from the to 2d videos with the 3d bone
shape we get 3d bones moving in 3d space
the software that combines the CT and
x-rays is the same kind of thing
Hollywood uses to do motion capture you
know that dudes wearing suits with balls
all of them we put little metal markers
into our animals and we use those like
the ball on the suit to register the
motion of the bones to the 3d CT scan
what you end up with is a look at the
inner workings of animals so what's the
point of Extron well for humans it's
about better understanding how joints
like knees work by watching them in fine
detail for things like fish it's about
new insights into how they feed with
suction power and with this 3d motion we
can get the way all the bones in the
head are moving get the expansion of the
head measure that power and figure out
where the muscle power is coming from to
produce these these incredible suction
events scientists can even use extra ohm
to look into the past in a way birds are
of course descended from the dinosaurs
dinosaurs of course left some lovely
tracks but the same dinosaur can make
vastly different tracks depending on the
consistency of mud by watching Ekstrom
captures of modern-day birds locking
researchers can better visualize how a
dinosaurs foot might have moved through
the muck
and that my friends is a step in the
right direction